al- muasi one of the last remaining
refugees for tens of thousands of
Palestinians many of whom have spent the
past 8 weeks fleeing further and further
south to escape from Israel's war on
Gaza here they have set up makeshift
tents on the sand Israel has labeled
this a humanitarian safe Zone but it is
not safe and it is not
Humane children died because of the
freezing conditions here our life is now
focused on how to find bread the
Israelis kill people with missiles and
shells and we are about to die here
because of the lack of everything that
can Keep Us Alive they send us here to
face a slow death if the Israelis don't
kill us the current conditions here will
definitely send us to our death Kadija
says she'd already been told to move
three times before she set out for
amarasi and she says there's no help
here at
all medicines are not available I am a
cancer patient and I have big problems
in my heart and I cannot endure or
tolerate it anymore there are no toilets
what can I do am I supposed to urinate
in front of everyone I don't even know
anything about my sons are they still
alive have they lost their lives I have
no idea IDF soldiers are just kilometers
away in KH Unis and the Palestinians
here hear the air strikes every
day there are huge numbers of tents here
that host huge numbers of people and
more and more people are coming every
day from car Unice ANS and flies and
other insects fill the tents we live in
a catastrophic
situation Yesa abui worked for the icrc
in Gaza after spending years in the
United Kingdom working as an engineer he
hasn't seen any Aid being distributed
anywhere in alasi it's not a matter of
Hamas or abuin or Egypt or Israel it's a
matter of our small children we're not
animals we're people we're human beings
even if there was a mistake that has
been done whatever you can't punish all
the people because five or
10% okay so we need we need the solution
if you if we're waiting to die for sure
three 3 weeks time people are going to
die from po no food no medicine no
meditation no
nothing if it if the matter is you're
waiting for us to die okay we're not
going to suffer anymore I'll just sit
down and wait for
death Joe Levens outz
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer